all right let's do it ladies and
gentlemen
welcome back to your absolutely
favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back to riffing
with griffin once again we're doing it
doing it well instead of sitting behind
my desk i'm sitting over here
at the in the rift griffin side of the
room
um i want to thank everybody for
watching if you uh please subscribe
share like do all that stuff um i
i game every day on twitch so make sure
you check out eric griffin gaming
and i do have more guests and stuff
coming in the future but as always thank
you all for watching
all right whatever i think is that like
your favorite part of the podcast is
that i do that part live
people tell me that all the time they're
like oh you got to keep doing it when
you don't do it you gotta do it live i
gotta get my ipad
there we go so i gotta have my ipad for
some of the stuff
that i'm gonna be talking about today
but anyways
welcome back to uh riffing with griffin
y'all and
let me see where is it uh okay yeah
here's some stuff i wanted to talk about
so i got it right here
all right so first let me just say this
you know i i
the podcast you know like i had santino
on last week
and i don't know why but we just get
into it and then we just start talking
about stuff
just politics comes up because that's
like that's the nature of where we are
right now but
uh i'm promising you on this episode
i've decided like i said you know what
we've had enough politics
so i'm only going to talk about one
thing and that's just the inauguration
you know [ __ ] bernie sanders was the
hit of the inauguration
yeah you guys noticed that like all
those memes i even did one you haven't
it's on my instagram right now where i
have bernie sitting over there and i'm
doing
the reference griffin intro so the
inauguration it is what it is
you know i i don't what what happened to
all the protests that were going to be
in 50 states and there was going to be
people at every capital
protesting nobody was there
nothing happened uh it was also boring
as hell look
i hope biden is a better
president in terms of like what he
actually does than he is a speaker
because he is not a motivational speaker
at all
i mean clinton was asleep it was crazy
so but you know we'll see what happens
in the future for that and
you know as i said this is the only
thing i'm gonna talk about this episode
about this like listen if there was ever
a president that had
say his own justification or or whatever
reason not to show up to the
inauguration because he didn't want to
be embarrassed
or he didn't want to you know because he
didn't like the person and didn't want
to be embarrassed about something that
he did
it was barack obama first of all let's
remember that
trump was constantly on that birther
stuff
his birth certificate he was going on
for a couple of years about how obama
wasn't a real citizen
he was leading that charge right
you know questioning his questioning
obama in
so many different ways in the media and
just he was unsure he was in the
forefront of that
then at the correspondence dinner obama
killed him right yeah whoever wrote his
jokes but he has some really funny jokes
and he was
giving it to trump as if like i see you
later
so then the guy wins demolishes your
party
makes just makes a mockery of the
political system shows
how just how double talk it is and
trump was just so different and then now
he beat your candidate
and you have to sit there and and and
have him come to the white house where
you were roasting him at this
correspondence dinner
after all that and just kind of like
sucked that up and he did it
he did it graciously even though he
hated the dude
even though he had every reason to be
like i ain't going to this no but he
carried himself with with grace and
style
he was presidential the fact that trump
didn't show up to the inauguration
the inauguration for all you people that
are always sending me messages about
trump oh man you do trump supporters
all you people are you trolls that hit
me up about whatever
what happened where's your boy
disgraceful as his last act as president
just a disgraceful disgusting act
just show what kind of person he really
is so
good riddance anyways that's all we're
gonna talk about with that guys
no more politics i want to talk about
some shows and stuff that i've been
watching
uh recently let's get into that
you know there's a lot that's actually
some good stuff
and then i also want to talk about the
nba
yeah let's just you know let's just have
some fun fun topics today
so let's talk about the nba first
actually
first of all let's say this because
today's sunday you know i record i
actually recorded the night before so
uh congratulations to um tom brady
for making it to the championship again
listen i'm a tom brady hater
i'm a doubter i always say yeah he's
just a game manager and
you know is he the greatest of all the
time he proved today he's the greatest
of all time
that that whatever you say about him if
he don't show it
with skill what he shows with just
his willingness to win and make people
around him better and not making
mistakes
he don't got to be the most skilled
player of all time he don't he
because his mind makes up for all that
the dude's going to the championship
again he did it without belichick
yes that team is stacked yes but that
same stack team
they were just a stacked last year and
had a guy throw for 5 000 yards
you know uh jameis winston threw for 000
yards last last year
and he just had 30 interceptions i mean
if he had done better maybe they would
have done better
but now you had a guy that could do it
at 43 years old he's he
taking down aaron rodgers so all that
aaron rodgers talk
which i'm a big fan of aaron rodgers i
think the dude is just phenomenal his
skill level is great but he don't know
how to get
he don't know how to get past he can't
get his team to galvanize and be
champions tom brady know how to do that
and he did it right if he beats patrick
mahones
it's done he should ride off into the
sunset he should just be like i'm 43
i'll prove to all y'all i didn't need
belichick i'm the reason why we won
bye and just leave with your
championship now on the other side if
patrick mahomes wins
this would be first year mvp
they should have went to the super bowl
that year but there was that pre-snap
pre-snap penalty against the patriots
which was nonsense
they should have went that and they
probably would have beat the rams too
but anyways he wins the mvp
he goes to the super bowl super bowl mvp
and then now this year
for his first three years in a row
starting that dude is he's
already letting tom brady know uh make
sure you beat me because if you don't
people are already gonna say i'm better
than you and i'm the greatest of all
time even with just two super bowls
just just the accomplishments that he's
done
already so kudos to to that
to both of those gentlemen uh you know
starry bill's mafia you didn't make it
but uh good good run they they they have
they're looking good for the future
and you know like i say and aaron
rodgers maybe they'll come back next
year and they'll do it again
you know he he was close last year you
know that's two
nfc championships in a row i believe i
think he was in there last year too so
all right nba my clippers are doing good
but i ain't going to talk about the
clippers i want to talk about
the nets so the nets got kyrie irving
james harden and kevin durant now and of
course everybody's like oh man they're
going to win a championship
you know you have a lot of people to
think like this is a dream team it's a
big three
they should be able to do it but i want
to pump the brakes
on it and remind people of some things
that have happened
in these particular gentlemen's past i
even took a screenshot off of this
stats website one of these good nba stat
websites
okay and i just want to point out
let me see which whose is this yeah this
is
this is james harden so first of all
let's just start with james harden okay
he's a phenomenal talent
outstanding scorer he's proven that
but what he's also proven is he can't do
it when it matters
i take no pleasure in saying that i love
basketball i love watching his game
but when the lights are bright james
harden does not produce
now i want to remind you let's go back
to
the oklahoma city days so oklahoma city
is playing miami in the championship
they got westbrook kevin durant and
james harden is coming off the bench
he's balling all year i just want to
point
out in that championship game they lost
they won game one and they lost four
games in a row
in the four games in a row that they
lost first of all game one
james harden was two for six okay
no impact but they won now the second
game he had a good game he was seven for
eleven
but they lost and then he went
two for ten two for ten
five for eleven okay but those the game
they they needed to win
all right game three and four
those are the games game four being the
pivotal game because then they were down
they'd be down
3-1 he went two for ten
to me i look at these numbers and i go
if james
james harden plays better in that
playoff series in that finals
oklahoma city might have beat miami okay
so let me remind you of that then let's
move forward
he couldn't play with dwight howard got
the dude shipped out of town
he gets chris paul they don't win with
chris paul chris paul shipped out of
town
they get they get russell westbrook
would they get right in pg right they
had uh
you know they had paul george he gets
shipped out of town
uh anthony what's his name
you know anthony's there he can't
he doesn't work with james harden no one
works with james harden
all right why is it going to work now
but that's
that's all i'm saying so i would pump
the brakes i'm not i'm not crowning them
champions yet or even getting out of the
east
just that's my one point all right let's
go to kevin durant
kevin durant another phenomenal talent
even better than james harden all right
even
better than james harden but i also want
to point out
he didn't shine in that championship
round against lebron james in the uh
his first time around in oklahoma city
it didn't work
it wasn't working with him in westbrook
whatever for a reason now
they play against the i just wanna they
play against
golden state in the championship in the
western conference final
they're up three one
okay they won three of the first four
games
they're up 3-1 all right now
i just want to point something out to
you in game five
game six and game seven but
five and six are the pivotal games in
that series
they could have won and went to the
championship
okay kevin durant was
12 for 31 in game five
wait hold on eight for 24
in game four that they won he was eight
for 24
then he went 12 for 31
in game five and then 10 for 31
in game six
terrible when it mattered
then they go on they lose
and then he leaves and goes to golden
state where
a talent like that on a 73 win
basketball team
it's gonna shine you know the pressure's
not on him
to be the best player they already got
an mvp on the team they already got
chemistry
so it worked now i'll say this
maybe because of that experience the
he got past those big game jitters
when the lights are bright maybe he got
past that because of that experience
beating lebron playing well maybe he got
past that
but again he wasn't necessarily
the sole best player on the team
he was surrounded by a team that had
already won a championship and won 73
games
but i feel like he's probably past that
now here he is
now he has the achilles injury now
people now
most people don't come back from an
achilles injury the same
but also most people don't come back
after they have 18 months off also
so maybe maybe in the league in the past
somebody would have been able to come
back if they just sat out for two years
you know what i mean like if they just
sat completely sat out for two years
instead of trying to come back for the
season
maybe that's why nobody's come back
because he looks like he's a hundred
percent
you know because he was never really a
super athletic guy he was all he's just
seven foot he could dunk and all that
stuff but his game is finesse and
shooting and
skills so so you have kevin durant
so i'm not sure about karen i'm not
calling kevin durant a choke artist
i'm just saying i've never seen him be
the best player
on the team where he like clearly he's
the man we're gonna win because of him
i want to see him do that now with the
nets let's see when the lights shine
bright in those
championship games is he gonna be the
one i think that he can't do that now
because of his experience with golden
state
okay but i'm saying we haven't seen it
because the last time
that was the situation he wasn't doing
well with his co-star
and he sucked when it mattered right and
then he went to golden state
but like i say i still think he he of
the three has the ability now you have
kyrie irving
when he was with cleveland pre lebron
they were terrible
terrible they get lebron they go to four
straight finals
he doesn't want to be with lebron
anymore he goes to bro
the boston he destroys the chemistry on
that team
there you could look at the numbers they
were better without them
okay and he's a phenomenal talent okay
then he goes to the nets last year they
were terrible
it's once again chemistry issues so
i'm just asking all you people out there
to think the nets
are are gonna do it
how why tell me what they've done
you know tell me what they've done
that makes you feel like oh this is
supposed to work
because i think that chemistry psyche
defense and all those kinds of things
that come together
play a factor in the team the success of
a team
and a proven leader proven like lebron
james has proven now
he is just he's you already got an
argument for him being the greatest of
all time all right
he's won championships in three
different cities
and he's he galvanized all those places
and they won he got the best out of
every single person on that on on the
squad
to win including the coach by the way so
we'll see net's lakers championship
would be phenomenal but
i don't know okay i don't know so anyway
that's my next talk um
all right so i watched a couple of
movies and i want to talk about them
all right now first let's talk about
this tv show one division
so i saw the first two episodes of wand
division if you have disney plus now
i've talked about the streaming services
before and i'm
and i'm just telling you that disney
plus is just it's worth having disney
plus if you have hulu
if you have hulu you have no business
not having disney plus
okay because it's it is a um
it's just like a dollar more and you get
espn hulu and disney plus
so if you're a hulu person you have no
business not having disney plus so go
ahead and get that bundle and get it
so anyways you know uh what do you call
it wanna vision is on the marvel
section of disney plus and it's called
one division and it's
some weird [ __ ] man i gotta tell you um
weird i'm not sure what's happening and
just if you were just watching it
without knowing
anything about the marvel universe i
don't know if you'd like it i don't you
might be like oh what is this
it's like you know so it's like it seems
like it's some weird 50s sitcom
you know they got the laugh track they
got they're making these weird jokes
but weird things are happening okay it's
in black and white
and there's still splashes of color and
i think that is used as some sort of
like
way of showing that something weird is
happening in this world that's not what
you seem
so i guess if you're looking at it i
guess i have to wait till i've watched
the whole season then i can look back
and be like oh that was great how they
started it
but so far it just seems weird so wanda
and vision from
the the avengers you know they're
they're like
like a like a 50s couple and it's like
this funny
sort of i love lucy sitcom going on in
there and they're making like
you know they're they're making little
references to all the old school sitcoms
so that's kind of cool but
i don't know what's happening but weird
like i say weird little things are
happening during it
and it makes you go oh i wonder like is
this all in her head
is she in a coma is she hooked up to
some machine
or is wanda been captured and they're
trying to like break her by putting her
in this
weird state you know we don't know
what's happening
so so that keeps you watching if you are
a huge
mcu you know marvel cinematic universe
uh fan so because of
because at last we saw vision he's
supposed to be dead right
thanos killed him because they never
yeah because they didn't they can't they
couldn't bring him back because
like with the snap like i just don't
know
like did captain america go back like
you know at the end of end game
i would have really liked to see like i
think a whole great movie
like a side movie even if they don't use
the dude that plays captain america
let's say they just got a different
actor to play this so we could see this
i would love to see captain america
returning the
the the stones the infinity stones
i would love to see him returning him to
the timelines you know
because he had to take thor's hammer
back and he had to take and he had to go
put the
he had to go put the uh you know the the
the the whatever that one stone is
back into the girlfriend of thor
right then he had to take dor's hammer
back you know then when he went back to
the time
lady you know um the master the whatever
warlord master lady you know what the
bald one i forgot i'm terrible at this
kind of stuff but
you know he she'd be the coolest one
because she would already know oh okay
you here bringing this back
cool thank you because i gave it to the
hulk and then now you gave it back
you know all that stuff like what
happened when with loki
like like at that moment there he has to
bring it back there
he has to you know what i mean like
there's so many
how did he do it like that's like a
whole
great story there because remember in
the elevator scene with the staff
so he would have to bring it back so
that means he would have to like
is he gonna meet up with his his other
self that came back because then there'd
be three captain americas
in that universe at one time so there's
a captain america
you know that yeah right it'd be three
they're fighting and then the he would
have to come back again
watch himself fighting and be like yo
here's this
like what would he do like i wouldn't i
want to see how all that played out it's
like
it's a mind bender you know so that
would be a a
a fun thing but what i'm saying is like
when when the hulk snapped did he
he didn't bring vision back because
vision needs the stone
right so at what point does he does he
go back and fix
that like why couldn't he just gone back
i don't even know
god i'm so confused now like why is
vision alive basically
because he's still even in the show he
has the stone in his forehead
so we know that he couldn't possibly
have that stone so
you know this again the show's weird so
you you kind of want to know where is it
going
like i said the ode to the old uh
sitcoms it's kind of cool and all but at
the same time i'm like
because it always ends with like it
seems like there's some
sort of control room that's controlling
like you know
there's some kind of mission control
that's how they always end the episode
hinting at there's something else going
on so i've only watched the first two
episodes i know another one came out and
i haven't watched it yet
but i did want to talk about it a little
bit it's kind of interesting like i say
if you're a huge fan of
the avengers and the marvel universe and
you want to check out
uh you know this to kind of to keep it
going and you got nothing else to do
i would recommend watching it but just
know that you're watching it for the
long haul like you can't just
watch this the first two and be like eh
because even if it's a little boring
even if it's a little like i don't know
what the hell is going on
i do feel like there is some end game
uh no pun intended uh to
what we're gonna find out about you know
wanda and
vision what happened to them all right
make sure i'm not looking too fat
okay so that was one division my little
crazy little review on wandervision
people keep asking me like hey how'd you
lose your weight i lost weight i just
eat better now that's all
i'm just eating better i'm taking my
vitamins and doing things like turmeric
and i'm taking fish oil and i'm just
doing all that old man stuff to like
take care of myself from turmeric for
the inflammation and
um you know vitamin c i'm taking b12 i'm
taking
vitamin d a lot of people are vitamin d
deficient and they don't realize it you
know
it's a surprising amount amount of
people don't get enough sun
and sun isn't actually even enough you
know so if you think about it now you've
been indoors a lot too
some of us during this pandemic so and
then it does affect you that you haven't
got now so make sure you check on your
vitamin
d man make sure you're getting enough
vitamin d so that's what i've been doing
you know and i try to take walks went on
a walk today with rachel but i want to
start actually
working out so i could build some muscle
and all that stuff too so look out
look out for that for me all right let's
talk about this other show
i want to talk about a couple of movies
that i watched
so i gotta i gotta pull out the ipad
so this this one movie i saw and this
was one of those movies that was
supposed to come out in the theaters
right
and then it um
[Music]
and then the world went crazy right
and then it just the movie industry
stopped and then now they're starting to
do it where they figured it out where
they're going to put movies in
you know they're going to go to hbo max
they're going to go to netflix whatever
at the same time as
the other states that are opened up
could go into theaters but for all of us
you know for the rest of us
this is um you know we we we have to
watch it
like this so this first movie is the
invisible man
i just saw it i think it's on hbo max
yes hbo max
the invisible man man i gotta tell you
this was a pretty this was a actually
pretty good movie
so the movie stars elizabeth moss
and this lady she is just
the master at playing a victim okay
she's just great she's from handmaid's
tale she's the star of handmaid's tale
you know she ain't like a bombshell
like you know she ain't mega fox
she's you know what i mean i'm not i'm
it's just she has an
aura about her that is beyond like just
looks and appearance
you know she's she she ain't got like a
like like you know
one of these like model bodies nothing
like that you know what i mean she just
she
takes regular just a regular average
person and and turns it with her persona
into just these really magical
performances
and she gives one in this one too man so
yeah elizabeth moss she starts she's the
star
so the movie opens up right spoiler
alert i'm not trying not to give away
too much but
but you already kind of from the trailer
you can kind of like figure out
some of the things but just watching how
it goes through because the movie opens
up great
the movie opens up and you get the sense
that
this woman is in a terrible marriage and
she she has to get out
so the movie opens with her with this
plan to escape her husband
you know and the way she plays it you
are scared for
her and you must think this guy must be
just the worst
like kind of like that jennifer lopez
movie where it's kind of a mixture of
that remember that
which get out i think that was the name
of it where jennifer lopez has to escape
her husband and she learns how to fight
and all this whatever
this is similar type of thing she's
grabbing her you know she's grabbing her
passport and she got money and she like
calls her friend and it would turn out
to be her sister and she like
has to escape you know and then but the
guy's like a brilliant scientist
you know and he has found a way to make
himself invisible
and the way they do that too totally
believable
you know i love like movie science you
know when movie science when they do
something you go oh i believe that just
how they set it up even though
it's not true it's like iron man like
the first iron man i loved how they set
that up
because the way they did it in the way
that he played the role
you believed that he made this suit and
he it could fly and all this stuff just
the way they did it
it's just it's a trick of the mind so
and this the science in this was great
but like i say she was so good
in it and i do recommend watching it
it's kind of one of those movies where i
don't even know if i would have seen it
in the theaters
you know because it's just like oh here
we go the invisible man
but like when you can watch a movie at
home and really just kind of like sit on
your couch and i turn the lights off and
i was like
oh it was like creepy and you know and
you felt for her
you like she was in such a crazy
situation because her husband was kind
of like
he was messing with her because you know
he faked his death
i mean listen this isn't giving away
this this is all everything in the
trailer okay
so but like i say it was one of those
movies that i was like
oh wow this movie got messed up because
of kovit because of the pandemic
this like movie just kind of fell under
the radar but people
actually probably would have really
enjoyed it and she gave a really
outstanding performance
so you know i say kudos to her
um for for what she did so
like i say i highly recommend
um the invisible man
now the other movie i just saw last
night
took me two days to watch it because i
had to stop because it's so
just and this movie came out in 2013 but
it just came to streaming
it's one of those movies that you never
would have saw in the theaters
it didn't make any money it was one of
these artsy fartsy
totally artsy fartsy movie but it stars
scarlett johansson from marvel universe
she plays
black widow right and it's called under
the skin
and guys i gotta tell you this movie
it was bananas like just
everything that happened in this movie
it's an art piece it's one of those kind
of movies that
there's symbolism and the things you see
on the screen it may not mean
what it means they might be like you
know
it's just an artsy fartsy like the type
of movie that like
artsy fartsy people would sit around and
talk about for hours
talking about the symbolism and and the
you know
the analogies to this and that and this
is like the
uh it just it was crazy so
let me just tell you about the movie so
under the skin it's about aliens
okay scarlett johansson's character is
an alien
so it's about these these aliens who are
obviously they're doing something
they're examining humans or they're
they're just trying to figure out what's
going on with human beings and they do
it in a very
serial killer stalky way so she's
driving around
in a van in wait let me find it like
it's
in europe too in glasgow you know
so she's driving like the movie opens up
where
a like a movie opens up with a dude gets
off a motorcycle and it's like
in the imagery like like it's like a
three-minute intro
of just a light getting bigger on this
it's like that kind of [ __ ]
you know what i mean it's very like like
remember
the the movie they made in in um
in the ring so remember the video like
the artsy fartsy video
that that was the scary video but how
archie fartsy it was
this movie was like that
you know so the movie opens up where
like this motorcyclist who's obviously
an alien too
who's with her or she hypnotized him i
don't even know
okay so she
he like gets off his bike goes like
off screen sort of into a dark area and
then he comes back with a woman
carrying a woman over his shoulder puts
her in a van
right then the next scene scarlett
johansson who is butt
ass naked okay by the way
if you want to see skull on your hands
and naked this is a movie to see
but it ain't gonna be what you think
that's the thing about it like
of all the times for her to do nudity in
a movie she's had plenty of chances to
do nudity and maybe in a mainstream
movie and maybe for
the way she did it in this there ain't
nothing sexy about it it's really creepy
you know and it's really like i said
this is a classic example
of like when you hear an actress or
someone talk about well i'll do nudity
if it supports the scene or if it moves
the story like
you know that sort of [ __ ] excuse
for doing nudity or not doing nudity
this movie is literally it this is
literally
one of those we those movies where you
go oh you did this nudity because it
actually
works perfect for this now listen she's
already been in the avengers in this
right like it's so
the choices and i know it was a choice
this is why i'm saying what i'm about to
say
it ain't even like she was in great
shape you know
she really was like a regular chick
you know what i mean like she didn't
have six-pack abs she didn't you know
she was she was thick you know what i
mean i was like okay
you know she was like she was that white
girl think that a lot of black dudes
gonna watch this movie and be like
what's up girl okay scarlett
okay so she was like it was
and that and to me i felt like it was a
choice i felt like maybe they had a
discussion like well do you want to get
in shape for the movie and then she said
nah
i don't think i should be in shape i
think i think i should be
an average woman because that's what
this alien is this alien beca
you know but she was still beautiful by
the way you know i'm just saying
you would think the vanity of hollywood
if you're going to be in a movie like
that
if you're going to be nude at all in a
movie you want to look your best
you kind of feel like that's how people
take it you know because it lasts
forever it's going to be on the internet
it's going to be everywhere
so she was but ass naked in this movie
and it was just really well done
you know what i mean totally move this
story but anyways
so they get this woman and then scholar
johansson this woman is comatose
and she undresses her takes off the
woman's clothes and it puts
that woman's clothes on and this woman
is just butt ass naked
on the ground and you see a tear come
out her eye right you're like what the
[ __ ] going on
and then the rest of the movie is
scottie johansson driving around in a
van
trying to pick up men okay and then when
she picks up them and she's like
it's so understated her performance like
there is no there isn't a lot of
dialogue in the movie
the music is like that kind of like
captivating strings and it's
creepy and the music moves the story and
the
imagery of like you know she's looking
for men because they did this montage of
all the men that she sees and she's
driving and it's just like
regular dudes walking around glasgow you
know and um
she picks them up sort of seduces them
and takes them back to like some place
you kind of think it's a spaceship or
something and then you know
she she's undressing and then they're
following her on this like
black surface and they're walking and
they're walking and then they
and then the the guy ends up by that's
naked now
if you don't want to see a lot of dick
in a movie
because then you don't want to watch
this movie either because there's a lot
of dick in this movie like a lot of dick
okay
like an uncomfortable amount of dick is
in this movie and
erect two you know it's just crazy
like again moves the story
okay so like and then something happens
to the guys and i won't tell you what
but
her as an alien she's like discovering
what it is to be human
and she has all these weird experiences
and then there's this
really crazy ending you know where you
like
you know you're gonna see what she
actually looks like under the skin which
is the name of the movie um
i'm just saying it was a really it was
the first time in a long time i've
watched a movie and like
kind of had to go huh and not in a bad
way of like what the hell was that about
because it was
bad and it just made me feel like damn i
might have to watch just again did i
miss something um
you know is it is it like is is this a
symbolism for
sexual experiences that we have is
who does she represent who am i in this
movie
which you know i mean it's just so many
it's just a mind-boggling experience
look you got nothing else to do so i
highly suggest that's my recommendation
my recommendation is to watch the
invisible man
on hbo and i think you should watch
under the skin a 2013 artsy movie
with scarlett johansson and i think that
under the skin i think they're both on
hbo right now actually yes i believe so
i think they're both on hbo
so make sure you check that out
[ __ ] i don't know how much time i've
been yip yapping with you guys so far
but uh i actually know make sure also
you watch me
on eric griffin gaming
i game every day on twitch so make sure
you guys uh
check that out i think i got some more
time to keep talking about stuff because
i i saw
i just realized that i did see another
movie that
i want to talk about i did you guys see
the
i don't know if you saw this uh
movie that came out this year uh
christopher nolan movie
tennet tenet tenet t-e-n-e-t
uh with um what's his name john david
washington
which is denzel washington's son um
and he's great he was in uh the hbo with
the rock
why am i forgetting ballers he was like
a receiver in ballers
but tennant this [ __ ] is another one
that
i don't know what the hell happened in
this movie man
it's like a time travel movie but not a
time travel movie
like it's like things were happening in
reverse it's just this christopher nolan
sort of um inception
like this is like this would be
happening within its inception i felt
like you know he's always trying to make
movies like that
i don't know if this movie was good or
bad i mean honestly i
i i just don't know like on wikipedia
you look up the plot and it says
all right so the cia protagonist
participates in an extraction operation
right so there's this big operation that
starts and uh they're
extracting someone it's like they're a
part of some secret organization
and then like a bullet instead of the
bullet shooting out of the gun the
bullet came
like the the bullet shot was already
there
and then the bullet came into the gun
and so then it's like
the movie's about how the future they're
sending technology to the past
and it's sort of time travel and
i just i don't know i my brain hurts
even just thinking about it but um
robert pat patterson the new batman he's
in it you know from twilight
he's actually great in this and he's
he's playing a british character for
for i haven't seen him do that in a
while i mean because i don't watch all
those movies i'm sure he has
but this is the first time i've seen it
and he's very grown up and he's like
he's actually a really great actor you
know it's like
you if you think of him from twilight
and harry potter you might think like oh
it's just some like good-looking guy
that they got but he this guy's actually
a phenomenal actor he was great in this
but i just didn't understand what the
hell was going on in this movie i
i need somebody to explain it to me but
again
i i put up a tweet about it and then i
got all these messages people like yeah
i had to watch it five times or the
second time i understood
so i i soft recommend
um tennant tenet whatever ten
i don't know even how to say the damn
name uh
he's pretty good you know he's he's
little though
because i noticed like he's like the the
chick starring in the movie
like it was weird i don't know if they
were gonna be able to have a
romance but it did look weird is that
biased or is that like sexist it's like
you know what what is that
when the male lead is so
short and then the female is lead is
like so much taller than him it just
looks weird but
should that be weird you know i don't
even know am i doing am i doing
something wrong right now am i gonna get
is it is that a cancelable offense i
don't know
but it did look weird it's just one of
those things that you just go oh man i
do short
i mean tom cruise is short but you never
really notice it because they always
make sure he looks tall or he looks like
you don't notice his shortness but for
some reason in this movie you notice how
short
washington is it's really short so a
movie i'm looking forward to seeing is
that
the little things with denzel washington
and
um jared leto leto and uh
the dude that won the oscar for playing
the
not the journey but whatever
whatever that guy's name is you know he
was a mr robot
i forgot his name i'm looking forward to
seeing that but
i'm gonna put this out there right now
i'm noticing from the trailer
that you know denzel washington is a cop
jared leto is supposed to be like the
bad guy
that's how they're doing it in the
trailer but the things that they're
saying
i'm putting it out there now making a
prediction i haven't seen the movie yet
i don't know nothing about it i don't
know
you know because i i just just from the
trailers it looks interesting and denzel
washington is always great so i want to
watch dance at washington movies
but i feel like denzel washington's
actually the killer
i think denzel washington was the serial
killer and we're going to find that out
in the end
and i think that they've revealed too
much in the trailer
uh and then people that watch a lot of
movies and just have plots in their head
are gonna figure it out but i could be
wrong and i hope i'm wrong
right that's just the way we look at
that
but anyways guys yeah i think that's
gonna be it i had a long episode last
week with mr
santino so you guys make sure you check
that episode out if you haven't seen it
already
um you know i'll be doing i have some
more stuff coming
uh rachel is gonna be on in this month
so look out for rachel
and she wants to start her own thing you
know she was like sitting on my couch
she hates my couch and then she was
talking about it and then her friend
came over and they were talking
and they wanted oh we should start a
podcast and i was like why don't you
just start a podcast called
i hate my boyfriend's couch
they loved it and so like i might do
like a little 20-minute segment for
rachel about
her so it's like rachel i don't know if
it's rachel's corner i hate my
boyfriend's couch it'll be something
like that
and then maybe i'll launch her for doing
her own thing if you know who knows if
anybody will watch it
you [ __ ] are barely watching my
podcast so but anyways we're just doing
out here trying to make
content because this is all we could do
right now the world's going crazy
i'm not going to talk about politics but
we will say i hope that the vaccine
i hope this [ __ ] works we pump it out
even more
because i just want to get back to
normal guys i did a show the other day
um yesterday i did a show and i don't
even thought we were even
supposed to do a show but it was like it
was outdoors and
you know and it was like only like 30
people and they were
all spread out and i thought to myself
why
aren't we doing this like what's
happening that we can't do this i don't
know why we're not eating at rush
outdoors at restaurants here in
california i don't understand it
i don't understand it i've been to these
restaurants when you walk in
outdoors you're not near anyone is it
spreading here
more so than like anywhere else and you
know and by the way too
i'll talk about this other comic at this
show and like and it's like you know
some people are getting on comics like
you know these like progressive liberal
type people who are just like
they think you know you should you know
you should do your part you need to stay
at home and
socially distance and just like being
nazis about it
so that makes reminds me of something
else i'm gonna talk about too
it's like they're getting on us like you
know you're doing
it's like hey man we gotta live you know
people gotta live
there are people who this was their
whole life was doing comedy and making
money doing comedy
and then it got taken away and what are
we supposed to do so any chance we have
to like do our art form
and for some people to make a little
money it's like why not
are you crazy like so you know what's
funny about it is people say
you know people to get on comics for
doing these type of shows
you know but then you still you think
it's still okay for me to should i work
at starbucks
because check this out i'm one comic not
near
anyone they're all spread apart i'm
doing this show in front of these 30
people and then i go home
we don't interact or nothing but you but
i could work at starbucks
i could be behind the counter at
starbucks all day
and i bet you i see up 300 people
are right in front of me and i'm all
damn day
but that's okay like because because you
need your coffee
oh you need your coffee so you know or
you need
you need your [ __ ] delivered and you
need target open you need vons open like
you need all these things open
that's like well i mean that's different
but
i can't have a clearly safe
all safety precautions and measures are
being used i can't
be at a show i'm doing wrong for that
nah man you gotta rethink your
priorities
like this thing is we are not handling
any of this right
at all in my opinion but anyways no
politics
so we're gonna end it oh wait i did say
one last thing
because i need to know and i need you
guys to send me this i need i need
comments about
this messages and comments okay
so i rachel bought me a face shield so i
got this big ass
i wish i had it with me right now so you
can really see but it's a big face
shield you know it covers like from here
down to like
past my chin big fan it comes like this
so i go get
i'm going to get some coffee this
motherfucker's behind a a plexiglass
you know a blue bottle day behind a
plexi glass
i walk up i got my face shield on the
guy
with an attitude like do would you like
a mask
you know when he hands me a mask and
like a paperback
and i'm like you know you don't see this
[ __ ] what's this [ __ ] you don't
see all this [ __ ] on my face
oh well i'm pretty sure you need both
where's that huh where is it
is that true because if it is okay but
like to me it seems like
what i mean isn't it i'm stopping
whatever's coming off of me
maybe it's going down but it's not
flying down if that's the case it would
happen anyway
i it just pissed me off
i can't stand mask police man
the mask police there is a way you tell
some you ask
somebody to wear a mask there's a way
okay like don't be a part of the problem
you people need to get off your damn
high horse the way you like talk to
people about it you know
look at dude it's like you need you
you're gonna get
you're gonna get popped in the mouth
you're gonna do that [ __ ] to the wrong
person
okay like let's tone it down and
remember that we are still human beings
that deserve respect
regardless of political beliefs and all
that all right
so just tone it down a little bit like
how you talking to somebody about
the mask situation okay and on the same
turn everybody else
let's do our best to make everyone feel
comfortable and safe and if that means
wearing a mask even when you're
uncomfortable by it
we should just do it i hate wearing
masks that's why i don't go out
i barely go out when we go someplace i'm
always like i'll stand outside
i'm like okay you know i just like i
just let me stand outside i want to be
outside with my mask off taking in that
fresh air
i don't want to be around people because
people are
weird about it and i don't want to be
that person that's like i'm not going to
wear a mask no i get why i should wear a
mask
i hate it it just makes me uncomfortable
so i stay home
for the most part i'm home most of the
time so i can't wait to get my vaccine
because i want to have like a wristband
on or something like that vaccine hoe
[Laughter]
let's get back to normal god i want to
get back to normal so bad
you know what i mean guys i think you do
know what i mean
all right well that's all that's all
we're going to talk about this week
um make sure you catch me on uh air
griffin gaming
put the videos up on youtube i'm on
twitch every single day
i really appreciate you guys watching
listening subscribing
keep it up please share for me and you
know suggestions for guests and you know
because there are people are coming back
you know
i don't mind having people sit in my
chair over here and
see what happens in the future i wish
you all the best and i wish you all love
and happiness and
you know stay up and i'll see you next
week
you